alors finalement le ciel va vraiment
nous tomber sur la tête
ou plutôt le climat mais ne vous
inquiétez pas il existe des façons
d'agir pour réduire la vitesse avec
laquelle on fonce vallée degrés
supplémentaires
mais ces fameuses solutions dont tout le
monde parle et qu'on a l'impression de
ne jamais vraiment voir venir quelles
sont elles la première c'est la sobriété
soyons réalistes il va falloir repenser
nos modes de vie nos modèles de
consommation pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur en france il faut réduire
nos émissions d'un facteur 5 ça veut
dire cinq fois moins d'avions cinq fois
moins de voitures cinq formes en
technologie cinq fois moins de vianne et
surtout
cinq fois moins de chocolat
vous imaginez un peu les fort à faire
mais c'est pas tout je ne sais pas si
vous connaissez le giec ce fameux groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat mais dans
l'ensemble de ces scénarios le giec
associe systématiquement sobriété et
puis carbone donc parfait il suffit
d'augmenter ces fameux puits carbone et
adieu la crème solaire pour les ours
polaires
ok super mais c'est quoi un puits
carbone
un puits carbone ça réservoirs naturels
ou artificiels qui permet de prélever du
carbone de l'atmosphère de le stocker
durablement ailleurs dans ce puits
carbone et ainsi de réduire l effet de
serre
ce
moment là de mon discours je devais
normalement vous parler des différentes
technologies depuis carbone
faire dans les océans le soufre dans
l'atmosphère et
je me dis que c'est un peu dommage
en fait vous voyez moi je suis klimato
innovation liste je pense que la
technologie va nous sauver
et donc ça fait plusieurs mois que je
travaille à une innovation et s'en sort
sans vouloir me jeter des fleurs je
pense que j'ai trouvé la solution face
aux dérèglements climatiques
mais cette innovation j'en ai pas encore
beaucoup parler
et maintenant que je suis là devant 500
personnes je me dis je serai peut-être
mieux de tester un petit peu le marché
bon je me lance c'est décidé je suis
désolé pour les organisateurs du tedx je
perds un peu revoir le discours qu'on
avait prévu ensemble vous n'allez pas le
regretter
passons maintenant que toulalan un petit
peu tard donc c'est parti je me lance
donc c'est une innovation qui est
composée de trois modules un module
principal et deux modules
complémentaires qui va avoir un impact
massif sur le stockage carbone et qui va
vraiment pouvoir régler le problème du
dérèglement climatique
donc mon premier module c'est un grand
tube jeudi grange avait prévu plusieurs
dizaines de mètres mais je pense je vais
faire un petit modèle pour le poser sur
votre bureau il va stocker du carbone
pendant que vous travaillez ça permet de
développer un petit peu le marché tout
cas c'est un tube composé de fibres de
carbone s'est lui-même un piège à
carbone et au jeu gastal plan de
panneaux solaires qui vont utiliser
l'énergie du soleil pour capter le
carbone
mais ça suffit pas personne n'achèterait
un grand tube sont comme ça pour mettre
dans son jardin
donc j'ai réfléchi qu'est ce qui va nous
tomber dessus avec le dérèglement
climatique
la hausse des températures
donc je vais utiliser l'énergie du
soleil avec mes panneaux solaires pour
installer en plus un système de
climatisation qui va refroidir
l'atmosphère autour de mon tube
deuxième chose qu'on va se prendre sur
la tête avec le dérèglement climatique
la disponibilité en eau donc ce tube va
être plantés dans le sol grâce à une
grande sondes cette sonde elle va avoir
deux particularités
elle va permettre de filtrer l'eau je
pourrais la vendre dans toutes les zones
de stress hydrique
et puis elle va permettre de stabiliser
le sol donc je pourrais aussi la
commercialiser dans les zones où il ya
des coulées de boue des inondations dans
les grandes plaines agricoles dans le
sud de la france permettre de bien
développer le marché
troisième chose qui va nous tomber
dessus avec le dérèglement climatique
la disponibilité en nourriture donc
pareil je vais utiliser l'énergie du
soleil pour produire de la nourriture
donc vous pouvez acheter au choix le
tube modèle poires et des pommes modèle
broccolini modèle chocolat c'est au
choix
mais ensuite que faire de tout ce
carbone que j'ai stocké et c'est là
qu'intervient mon deuxième module
deuxième bout d'innovation c'est une
petite machine mobile vous mettez le
carbone comme combustible je comprend
pas que personne n'y ait pensé parce
qu'en fait hyper simple et après elle
fait ce que vous voulez donc elle peut
vous transporter d'un point a à un point
b semer des graines produire de
l'engrais tondre porter des charges
lourdes produire de la nourriture
c'est vraiment au choix
mais je compte vraiment développer mon
marché donc je vais avoir encore plein
de carbone stockée dans mes tubes et
donc c'est là qu'intervient mon
troisième module c'est vraiment un puits
carbone en creuse un trou on met le
carbone on referme
alors vous pensez quoi non innovation
est ce que vous aussi vous êtes persuadé
que ça va sauver le monde
elle est super on voit la motivation
vous dites que je dis n'importe quoi que
j'aurais peut-être dû rester sur mon
discours initial et que vraiment là je
divague que jamais cette innovation ne
verra le jour
et bien détrompez vous moi je suis prête
à parier que depuis ce matin cette
innovation miracle dont je vous parle
vous l'avez croisé au moins 150 x 650
forme différente
parce que oui cette innovation elle
existe déjà elle s'appuie sur un petit
peu de arrêt d environ 500 millions
d'années de r&d cette innovation miracle
c'est mon module numéro un type qui
utilise le câble l'énergie du soleil
pour stocker du carbone une plante aux
modules numéro deux machines mobiles qui
utilisent ce carbone comme source
d'énergie
un animal mon module numéro 3 1 puis
carbone long terme le sol en fait cette
innovation miracle dont je vous parle
depuis tout à l'heure c'est le vivant
c'est la biodiversité
alors on va reprendre un grand tube un
tronc module numéro 1 avec en haut des
panneaux solaires des feuilles qui
utilise l'énergie du soleil pour capter
le dioxyde de carbone rejeté de
l'oxygène et stocker le carbone sous
forme de sucre de glucose qui constitue
la base de la matière organique de la
matière du vivant mais en plus de
stocker du carbone ces plantes à nous
rendre de multiples autres services
grâce à l'ombre et à l'humidité qu'elles
génèrent elles réduisent la température
grâce à leurs racines elles filtrent
l'eau et elle stabilise le sol elles
produisent des fibres pour nous vêtir du
bois pour nous chauffer des molécules
pour la médecine elles nous rendent de
multiples services
et ensuite ces plantes qu'est ce qui
leur arrive elles sont consommées par
des animaux ça tombe bien c'est mon
innovation numéro 2
ces animaux une grande aussi de grands
services dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
alors on va prendre un premier gros
exemple celui de la baleine
la baleine durant sa vie qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait naviguer à travers les
océans à la cumul de la matière
organique dans son corps et quand elle
meurt toute cette matière tombe au fond
d'océan et le carbone et stocker
durablement
mais ce n'est pas tout la baleine durant
sa vie qu'est-ce qu'elle fait vraiment
qu'elle naviguait des fake et toute
cette matière d'alimentation au plancton
le plancton c'est notre vrai poumon
c'est 50% de l'oxygène produit sur terre
et surtout c'est un énorme stock de
carbone d'après le fmi le fonds
monétaire international
ce serait 37 milliards de tonnes
d'équivalent co2 de stock permanent
comme ça parle pas à grand monde en gros
ça fait quatre fois la forêt amazonienne
et donc plus on a de baleines plus on a
de plantons si on préserve les baleines
si on régénère la population de baleines
on stoppe plus de carbone aussi grâce au
plancton
mais ça c'est un exemple d'un animal
d'une interaction on pourrait prendre un
autre gros exemple celui de l'éléphant
l'éléphant il fait des trous et à
travers la forêt ça paye mais
régénération des écosystèmes et c'est ce
qui explique que la forêt africaine
stock davantage que la forêt amazonienne
mais je pourrais encore vous donner un
autre exemple d'un animal dont on parle
beaucoup trop peu dans la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique
la loutre
la loutre elle mange des oursins les
oursins mangent les algues les algues
sont des pièges à carbone en régulant la
population d'ours 1 les loutres
permettent de préserver le puits carbone
des algues
et j'ai pas du tout parlé des sols les
seuls c'est un énorme stock de carbone
c'est des milliers de milliards de
tonnes de stock stockées en permanence
en fait quand un animal un végétal meurt
la matière organique est dégradée on dit
qu'elle est minéralisées en partie dans
les sols et sa stockent le carbone
en fait dans la nature contrairement à
ce qu'on croit c'est pas l'arbre qui
stockent le carbone c'est les
écosystèmes dans leur ensemble et toutes
les interactions entre les éléments de
cet écosystème entre les animaux les
végétaux les champignons l'eau l'air le
sol
et alors nous brillant homo sapiens
qu'est ce qu'on fait de cette innovation
miracle qui nous rend tente service dans
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique
on l'a aimé repos on la détruit on l'a
bétonne mais c'est pas grave parce qu'à
la place on a mis quelque chose qui nous
rend beaucoup moins de services mais qui
génère de la croissance
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
on va prendre l'exemple d'un acteur qui
en général peut agir à large échelle ce
trail sur une grande chaîne de valeur
l'entreprise
les entreprises de plus en plus elle
vous parle de leur fameuse stratégie
neutralité carbone elle met en place des
actions de réduction des émissions ce
qui est absolument essentielle et elle
achète des jolies crédits carbone
mais comment on vient de voir que la
biodiversité été notre principale
innovation pour stocker du carbone
grande aide dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
on peut se dire que ça n'a pas de sens
de faire une stratégie de neutralité
carbone sans parler de biodiversité
et bien sûr une échelle de 1 à je m'en
préoccupe comme de mon premier gobelets
à café
on peut dire que la biodiversité se
situe en général
au niveau de priorité des entreprises
environ je dis bien environ c'est
d'après mon expérience personnelle
environ au nom au niveau d'une honda
graff utilisés chaque année
bon autant vous dire qu'elles n'ont rien
à faire
mais elles ont des bonnes excuses je
veux dire les moutons c'est vraiment pas
sérieux on peut pas mettre ça chez nous
les russes c'est dangereux imaginer
quelqu'un est allergique aux abeilles
mais où est ce que vous voyez de la
biodiversité on a tout bétonner ya que
des parkings sur notre site on n'a pas
de problème de bio dit la cpi si
vous vous doutez bien que ça c'est faux
vous moi les entreprises les territoires
on a tous un impact sur la biodiversité
alors l'équivalent du giec mais pour la
biodiversité a défini cinq facteurs de
pression des pressions qu'on exerce tous
au quotidien sur la biodiversité si on
réduit ces pressions on permet une
régénération des écosystèmes et donc de
protéger cette innovation de régénérer
cette innovation qui nous rend temps de
service dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
donc c'est un peu la formule que
j'aimerais que vous reteniez ce soir
c'est 5 pression et comment est-ce qu'on
peut agir au quotidien
alors on va se lancer
première pression la dégradation des
habitats
c'est par exemple la déforestation mais
c'est aussi tout ce qu'on appelle le
changement d'usagé des sols passer d'une
zone de biodiversité a par exemple un
terrain foot une exploitation agricole
intensive ou une plantation d'arbres
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire on peut
évidemment protéger les zones existantes
en recréer d'autres on peut privilégier
la rénovation au lieu du 9 privilégier
les zones poreuses au lieu d zone
bétonnée et surtout on peut agir au
quotidien par nos achats par exemple en
réduisant les technologies qui sont
responsables de dégradations par les
mines mais surtout par toutes les
infrastructures gigantesques qui
conduisent à ces mines ou par notre
alimentation est ce que ma viande et
nourris avec du soja ogm c'est à dire
susceptibles de venir d'une zone de
déforestation ou est-ce que mon huile de
palme de cacao mon chocolat est certifié
deuxième pression la surexploitation des
ressources la plus connue c'est la
surpêche on consomme plus que ce que
l'écosystème
régénéré là encore vous pouvez réfléchir
par vos achats est ce que mon poisson
mon bois sont susceptibles de venir de
pratiques responsables de
surexploitation
troisième pression le dérèglement
climatique la biodiversité n'a pas le
temps de s'adapter à la hausse des
températures
donc quand vous faites une action pour
réduire vos émissions vous faites aussi
une action pour protéger deux vivent
pour protéger vos puits carbone c'est
plutôt un cercle vertueux
quatrième pression la pollution on va
voir si vous suivez surexploitation des
espèces dégradation des habitats
dérèglement climatique pollution
la pollution c'est tout ce que vous
rejetez dans l'eau dans l'air c'est par
exemple les cosmétiques les produits
ménagers les pins tuer les produits que
vous mettez dans votre jardin les
aérosols vous pouvez essayer de les
réduire ou de prendre des produits qui
sont moins impactants pour
l'environnement la pollution si c'est
par vos achats encore une fois tous les
produits industriels
toutes les pollutions qui peuvent venir
de l'industrie en amont ou les produits
phytosanitaires par exemple donc
privilégier des produits bio ou agro
écologiques et puis toutes les
pollutions qui sont liées aux déchets
donc quand vous allez vers une stratégie
zéro déchet vous allez aussi vers une
stratégie pour protéger le vivant est
cinquième et dernière pression les
espèces invasives qui prennent la place
de nos espèces locales
donc la prochaine fois que vous revenez
de californie en bateau évidemment fait
attention à part amener une écrevisse ou
une tortue dans votre sac à dos et
privilégier plutôt les espèces locales
pour votre jardin
alors vous l'avez compris face aux
dérèglements climatiques on peut encore
agir mais il nous faut agir vite en plus
de la sobriété de la réduction de nos
émissions notre meilleure chance est
protégé cette innovation miracle qu'elle
vivant qu'est la biodiversité
pour ça on peut comprendre nos impacts
et les réduire on peut planter des
baleines on peut protéger les
écosystèmes
et quoi de mieux pour commencer ce
combat que d'essayer d'apprendre à
connaître ceux vivant dont finalement on
ignore quand de choses pour ça on peut
lire se renseigner écouter et surtout
laisser la place à ceux qui se font le
porte-parole de se vivre
merci beaucoup
camille